what inspired me is that we have this
amazing tool now that's that's very
quickly penetrating you know every place
on the world where you can have
point-to-point communication between
individuals all over it's possible in
limited ways to censor the internet but
I'm very much an optimist about that i
don't think the censorship can really
very much succeed in the long run and so
the idea that we can have a real
dialogue between people not between
governments or just between sort of
important pundits but ordinary people
can can talk about things in many
different parts of the world i think
that's really fascinating is going to
have some major and positive you know
implications for peace in the long run
it's no simple and easy process it's not
like you just sort of turn on the
internet and all of a sudden everybody
just has a reasonable conversation
instead of going to war it's it's more
subtle and complex than that but I think
it really does begin to make it possible
to see other people as human beings
rather than as the other and I think
that's that's going to be huge in a long